you do the hokey pokey and you turn  yourself around that's what it's all  about  but what if it is  what if the Hokey Pokey is  what it's all about the origins of the  brace Hokey Pokey are unknown but one of  the best theories in my opinion is that  it was first popularized as a funny  thing to say by being used to refer to  ice cream made with little tiny bits of  stuff in it this is supported by the  fact that Hokey Pokey may be a  Corruption of the Italian phrase okay  Poco meaning oh how little and isn't  that what we all are tiny things that  exist for about a moment of Galactic  time just long enough to stick a leg in  Shake It about and then Retreat back to  dust your experiences are gargantuan but  compared to the vastness around you what  if it's all about the Hokey Pokey  oh  how little